I'm going to begin the conversation this
morning as the three of us are sitting
here with sleet and freezing rain coming
down behind us here to ask you mr.
Sanders how Vermont has been faring with
all of the storms in them and what we've
had in the last week until this is this
is woman and lovely glorious weather
it's been really unfortunate we still
have people in slate or not many
thousands of people who do not have
electricity a lot of old people are
hurting very badly we've had to set up
some emergency shelters we lost the
whole lot of trees and tree limbs and
it's a run up quite a bill for the state
of Vermont in various cities in town so
it's in many ways it's been one of the
worst weather crises that we've had in
20 or 30 years are the public services
responding adequately did our guys a
very well trained I mean we I know in
here at Washington you see if there's an
inch of snow the whole city shuts down
and people can't get the work and the
rate don't go to school but in Vermont
were used to those type of conditions
and people many of our workers have been
out day and night and doing a fine job
well for all people without electricity
for almost a week now certainly we're
all thinking about them down here as
we're staying nice little more but let's
dig into the morning newspaper stories
mr. like your first time at the table
here this morning we'll start with you
and what you can read here thanks for
the coffee in the bagel certainly what
if you found in the paper that caught
your attention today well a little
parochial concern here in the front page
of the Baltimore Sun papers senator
young as you know is dominating the news
the Senate of Maryland he has going to
vote Friday to potentially expel a
member of the first time in 200 years
very serious matter a huge potential
impact when in Maryland politics this is
a major ally of the governor we're going
to have a close race anyway we had a
close race four years ago as you see
that's all the Baltimore Sun papers has
been the last few days and how have you
been following it well I've just been
following it's it's it's a very very
interesting development i was in
annapolis yesterday a sudden a young had
a rally had bunch of his constituents
come down to support him he has said he
will not leave voluntarily he will make
his colleagues so expel him that's going
to make for some very high tension in
the Maryland Senate in annapolis this
friday
Mr Sanders how about a story from you I
was interested in a story that appeared
on page three of the LA Times and it
talks about what's going on in Indonesia
bailout and so forth and so on I have
real concerns about the propriety of
this bailout using taxpayers money to
bail out large banks and billionaires in
Indonesia and the article points out
that Indonesia's president that's
general suharto who is a dictator in
that country has a lot of blood on his
hands and it's not a nice guy that he
and his six children have an estimated
net worth of 40 billion dollars now I
don't know but maybe I'm old-fashioned
but I kind of find it hard to ask
farmers in the state of Vermont to work
70 hours a week to keep the heads above
water and working people who are seeing
the client and their standard of living
to bail out a dictator named general
suharto whose family has worth 40
billion dollars so i think if he's
terribly concerned about the future of
his own country among other things he
might want to kick into some of that 40
billion bucks and I think we might want
to ask some of the banks who have made
billions of dollars in investments in
Asia and putting Chase Manhattan
Citibank and those folks who've made a
huge fortune but now they're losing
money and they want to go to Uncle Sam
and cry out for welfare well I think
they might want to bite the bullet a
little bit too so those are some of the
issues that concern me Susan explain how
the process works how is it that farmers
in Vermont might be called upon to bail
out people in Indonesia has got the
wrong got President Clinton should be on
the program and maybe Newt Gingrich to
answer that one I don't think that they
should I think yeah but we've got its
through two agencies number one it's to
the exchange stabilization fund and the
president has already committed billions
of dollars in that fund to the Asian
bailout and I have a real problem about
the process Bob Ryan Bob's view on it
but we didn't vote on that issue we
didn't discuss it on the floor of the
house president decided that he wanted
to use that money all by himself and I
have a real problem with that process a
second of all as I understand it in a
couple of weeks or so the president is
going to be requesting some 18 billion
dollars for the IMF increased funding
for the IMF to continue the bailout
process I have deep concerns about what
the IMF has done around the world I
think America has got to play a role in
dealing with poverty throughout the
third world but the record of the IMF is
spotty at best that has not necessarily
been successful bottom line is when your
banks that have made billions of dollars
you're billionaires like general suharto
and Asia who are very very wealthy I'm
not sure the middle class and working
families of this country have got to
bail them out but it's a really timely
issue for the house Banking Committee
we're going to have this to base early
when we come back and there may be more
of a common ground with respect to right
and left on this issue then many people
might think the United States has a role
to play in stabilizing markets and
assisting with poverty around the world
we all know that but as Bernie said the
record is spotty and the extent to which
American taxpayers should bail out
questionable institutions who make
questionable loans it is an issue that
is part of this entire debate so whether
you're conservative liberal whatever
Republican Democratic think many of us
are coming from this with a bottom line
protecting the American taxpayers
investment in doing the right thing the
United States does have an interest in
stabilizing world markets no doubt about
it anybody in this country has a mutual
fund has an interest in stabilizing
world markets but the bottom line is to
the United States be the the last resort
for every institution who makes a
questionable own around the world and
the answers now I mean I think an
interesting i think blog makes a good
but we're holding a conference later on
today which is going to be left and
right together we have some of the most
progressive organizations on some cato
institute and heritage and so forth very
conservative groups and essentially one
of the points to both groups of making
is the following under our system of
government if i'm a bank and bob comes
into me for a loan right and i don't do
a good homework good good process and
determining whether he's going to pay
back that loan i say Bob he has 10
million dollars and guess what he goes
out of business he can't pay back the
loan I don't usually go running to the
United States government in the
taxpayers this country's hey I lost
money lending money to this guy bail me
out but essentially that's what some of
these large banks are doing and I think
that that is very very unfair i think
that the United States does have a role
to play in making sure that the Asian
economies don't collapse that's bad for
the people of Asia and it will trickle
down to the people in the United States
but there are other ways of structuring
the process other than going I believe
to the taxpayer as more people have a
part in the health of our stock market
as the mutual fund explosion continues
of course and it reaches into the middle
class in America in the working class in
America we do have a role to play in an
interest
no doubt about it but as I said these
lines we need to debate and the
president acting unilaterally without
consultation with Congress is an issue
that both sides of the aisle are
concerned about we're interested in your
participation this morning if you have a
newspaper story that you like to add to
the mix we'd like to hear about it for
people who generally support the
Democrats we've got a line for you to 0
to 62 for 11 11 Republicans should use
to 0 to 62 for 1115 and others 2027 376
734 c-span also has a fax line and an
email address if you'd like to send your
comments that way our email address is
journal at C span org and I want to show
you one small item that was in USA Today
says that house banking panel led by
chairman Jim leach of Iowa heads for
Asia today to assess the regions
financial crisis was this a trip that
either of you had an opportunity to go
along I didn't know i er rotation was to
got lost in the mail just kidding but
I'm glad you brought this up because
there are such thing as boondoggles and
there are such thing as legitimate
congressional trips and in this era when
everybody's scared to do anything with
respect to travel or the AP or somebody
calls you and says what about this trip
you took and who did you take it how
much money did you spend and who
sponsored the trip obviously it in my
view I've been here three years Bernie's
been here longer most congressional
trips that I have seen are legitimate
there have been boo'd doggles that about
in the past i believe burn hey there may
have been more boondoggles I don't know
it's your comment on that but the bottom
line is this is a very legitimate trip
the house Banking Committee Chairman
should be over there with a delegation
we happen not to be asked on this trip
but the bottom line is I think it's very
legitimate for chairman Leach and
members of our committee to go over
there and check it out first hand well I
would agree with that but I think Susan
when we talk about the bailout one of
the things that really concerns me is
the following and Bob and I probably
don't agree on this is I have a real
problem that in recent years mr.
Gingrich and the president of the united
states have said to us g we have a large
deficit we have a large national debt
therefore we're going to have to cut
back on medicare despite the fact that
millions of Americans can't afford their
prescription drugs and are paying a
whole lot of money out of there
pockets we're going to have to cut back
on Medicaid we're going to have to turn
our backs on veterans will put their
lives on the line and defending this
country and cut back on the Veterans
Administration cut back on affordable
housing at a time when what people are
homeless cut back on the needs of kids
despite the fact that we have the
highest rate of childhood poverty in the
industrialized world so we're supposed
to do all of these things that are they
telling us well maybe we should even cut
back on Social Security but at the same
time in lightning speed you know for the
United States government they move
forward as quickly as you can think of
in coming up with 20 billion dollars to
bail out the banks here and some bad
folks some some people like general
suharto in Asia and that process
concerns me I wonder why it is that we
don't have enough money to take care of
our own people many of them are hurting
many of them are working longer hours
for low wages but we do have enough
money for general Zapata in the Chase
Manhattan Bank click comment never go to
call sorry a lot of the problem programs
that Bernie's mentioned obviously have
been sick over the years of various
reasons one of the major reasons is
inefficient spending by the federal
government so I'm not sure it's not
apples and oranges here but we'll get
into that more in a minute I'm sure
silver spring maryland first call the
morning welcome calling on the
Republican lines oh yes yes and I thank
you for letting me on the air the thing
I wanted to talk about is the inflation
rate I got the yesterday's Wall Street
Journal I don't have today's and in
there they talk about the inflation rate
only going up one ten to one percent
during the past month and one point
seven percent now a lot of people want
to go ahead and reduce the coal is
saying that the inflation rates
overstated if it's overstated by very
much we're in the area of deflation and
what they're going to have to do is cut
back on people's calls and there will be
a negative Cola and I'm i'm just
wondering of i I'm just wondering how
this can be handled because I I myself I
I can't tandem the idea that the
things have only inflated that much
everything that I touch seems to be
going up more than one temp to one
percenter one-point-seven percent a year
thank you sir i think is referring to
this the issue of the CPI being
overstated an extent to which inflation
plays into that we've had that debate in
the House Banking Committee nothing's
being done with the CPI in a very real
way but I have no reason to suspect that
inflation at this point is being
understated or overstated certainly
prices have been generally stable over
the last few years here's the problem
that you have with that objectively
speaking it is very very difficult talk
about inflation in a national sense of
you have a 20 year old kid in Los
Angeles and an 80 year old person in
Burlington Vermont right they don't have
the same needs my concern when we talk
about the CPI is the people like Alan
Greenspan and others are saying well we
think the computation of the CPI is
overstated and we've got to cut back
meaning smaller colas for citizens on
seniors on Social Security and I think
that that is outrageous I really do I
think let me ask you this parade why do
you think it's outrageous do you think
the basket that they look at is in some
way two reasons two reasons first of all
is the issue of need in my state and I
can talk about Maryland but in my state
when I go out to senior citizen centers
what I find is that many elderly people
despite Medicare these are folks are
trying to get by an eight or nine
thousand dollars a year many people
cannot afford their prescription drugs
they're cutting their doses and half in
my state and I think all over this
country health care any elderly people
having to make the choice between
whether they heat their homes and susan
was saying it gets pretty cold and nasty
and Vermont this time of year whether
they buy adequate food now in a country
which has the most unfair distribution
of wealth in the industrialized world
where the richest 1% own more wealth
than the bottom ninety percent with the
people on the top of making out like
bandits I don't think what you say is G
let's cut back on those elderly folks or
getting by re to 9,000 asya that's the
first point so it's a moral point view
the second point of view is how you
compute as I indicated before the needs
of a senior citizen in the state of
Vermont the 20 year old kid in Los
Angeles California frankly they're
different needs and I
think there have been some studies which
suggest that the needs of the elderly
primarily because of health care costs
are higher than the general population
no doubt about it whether it is
overstated or not is an issue best left
to the bureau of labor statistics as you
notice that the executive branch
function chairman Kasich may have a
different view but most folks in
Congress do not think that Congress
should move with respect to this issue
but if it is overstated I think the
majority of economists that I've talked
to or I've read do believe it is
overstated the CPI really drives this
entire thing I think we need to look at
it as as a legislative branch we need to
look at the entire issue and I think
that's fair we should have the economist
come before the Budget Committee and
testify with respect to a very important
issue you're talking about billions tens
of billions of dollars here I think
you're talking about two issues number
one if you're saying that we need an
objective non-political assessment I
agree absolutely i mean we want the
facts but i think even after we get the
facts we need to make some moral
judgments and the moral judgment i think
that we have to make and that we know is
that when you have senior citizens who
are trying to get by an eight or nine
thousand dollars ear we have veterans
will put their lives on the line we're
getting disability right now you have to
make that judgment matter what the rate
of inflation might be it's a way for an
issue it's a redistribution of income
now well no you're not no you're really
not what you really have to say is mr.
Greenspan and others would say we have
to cut back they have made that
assessment I'll tell you what let me be
very frank with you even and I don't
think this is the case there was an
objective assessment that said that G
inflation is a point higher than we
think it is therefore we're going to
have to cut back on Social Security and
Medicare I ain't going to go for that
too many people in my state too many
people throughout this country work
their entire lives and I'm not going to
take away a hundred dollars on them or
two hundred dollars a year from them
when they need that for food and then
see the Congress vote for tax breaks for
millionaires and Bonilla even if this
inflation occurs I guarantee it will
agree on this the Congress is not going
to vote I believe to cut the call is or
at least make a negative color well I
bet it's not going to happen to know
that there are a lot of folks more
Republicans I'm not a Democrat even
subtle I shouldn't get into that but you
know people like Alan Greenspan are
running around the country gee i mean
III find no Greenspan's fan now
there we go now we're honest I think we
could really this I'm not a great way it
was capital gains at zero I like well
what's the appropriate yeah and then to
not raise them in our tax rate yeah well
I don't I mean I think the end result is
and this is an important discussion I
mean it's our priorities as a nation and
I think we stand by the weekend the
vulnerable the kids you know we can talk
about the cows come home but let me just
say this I mean we have a nation which
has twenty-two percent of the children
living in poverty which is double the
rate of any other country on earth
millions of elderly people are barely
getting by I don't think you cut back on
those programs at the same time as you
bail out general suharto and give tax
breaks to billionaires that's why view
we're talking this great philosophical
discussion we've evolved into already I
think we have somebody wants to talk to
I'm gonna take a call from erie
pennsylvania i might ask well let's get
another call right off afterwards and
catch up on some of our viewer comments
eerie you're on the air and you're on
the Democratic line just weren't good
morning good morning well our paper
announces a Tom Ridge is going to go
into his reelection mode and he also
wants to not promised four full years
because he'd like to be captives vice
president that's not really what i call
to talk about because last week my paper
really surprised the first time in a
long time that I've really been startled
by something i read in the year or so
ago dick armey announced to me that i
was a commie pinko because I belonged to
the Nature Conservancy but I didn't
realize I was subversive because I liked
the movie It's a Wonderful Life and
apparently our FBI had this long catalog
of subversive movies and I take in most
of the movies that I really can remember
loving back in the days it's a wonderful
life mr. Smith goes to Washington the
best years of our lives the farmer's
daughter All My Sons I mean I'm amazed
that what i thought was significant
americana is considered subversive by
the Federal Bureau of Investigation I'm
going to wonder about those guys and
then what what what period of time are
you talking about though you're talking
about 30 years ago or today well the
forties I don't know what movies they
think are subversive today they haven't
given us salute do you think they still
keep lists with the support subversive
movies on it's a different error wait
mr. Hoover's no longer there well I
don't know whether that matters i mean
there's funny things
but if this is this is where the basis
comes from I'm sure that there's a lot
of people who work for mr. Hoover this
all comes from the work of a on a
professor at franklin and marshall
college but i really was stunned i
couldn't believe that anybody ever
thought it's a wonderful life with
subversive this professor has been
digging through some archives apparently
he's researching something and this came
out at differences by a Kevin Cooney Oh
who probably works for our local paper
and pretty sure he doesn't name is
familiar okay I was amazed at the SE at
the article thanks very much that's one
of the things we like about hearing
local papers and hearing different
stories from around the country let me
move on to another call on our
independent lines from crossville
Alabama you're on the air yes ma'am oh
this Johnny Helton and I was mist to the
guy's talking there about coalesce and I
was just kind of going to my mind with
all them millions of dollars being spent
on the investigation of the president
and stuff like that and then Congress
and everybody getting a two point three
percent raise narrow lane Howard's all
that money come in from it except the
third and I'll get to cutting all the
benefits veterans and senior citizens
and stuff like this how can they afford
spend all that money cut it out for
everybody else to work in but the money
in the government to be spent well it's
the way this administration acts doesn't
help even when they do nothing wrong
this administration acts like they
performed a guilty Act there have been
more scandals in this administration or
it's the most cynical administration in
my view certainly in my lifetime so I
certainly disagree with your premise and
I had that observations well your
premises everything's being cut and
nothing's being cut some things are
growing slower than they used to nothing
really is being cut the welfare state
today as larger than it's ever been but
with respect to this administration I
think it's a very legitimate function of
the legislative branch to investigate
the executive branch that's what
Congress does that that constitutionally
that's what we're supposed to do and
that takes money when you have the
Clinton administration it's a record is
quite clear if we can ever get all the
documents and get all the folks who have
fled the country to ever testify maybe
we could even find out more but it's a
very legitimate thing for the
legislative branch Sylvester
executive branch it's Washington it's
politics it gets ugly it gets rotten it
makes us both uncomfortable I think
Bernie and I can agree that it gets too
politicized in this in this place here
on this hill but the bottom line is
there are very serious allegations
concerning what the Clinton
administration has done over the past
few years particularly with respect to
foreign money and influence on on policy
of the United States and that is a very
legitimate thing for Congress to do but
let me just say this i think as i
understand that the gentleman was
calling up and saying how can we talk
about making cuts in colas when we spend
the money all over the place and we can
get into the president and campaign
finance and all that stuff in a second
but i think the gentleman's point is
basically correct the priorities that
have been established by the united
states congress by in my view both the
Republican and Democratic parties are
absurd and the results are very apparent
I think Bob is incorrect when he says
that there are no cuts there really are
cuts when you look at inflation there
are cuts in Medicare there are cuts in
Medicaid there are cuts and veterans
programs there are cuts in affordable
housing there are cuts in the needs of
our children and a lot of people will
hurt as a result now why does that take
place why do we give billionaires tax
breaks and then talk about cutting back
on the cost of living and social
security but this takes us to an article
I'm cheating a little bit Susan I must
give us this was yesterday's that's our
exam all right that's yesterday's Boston
Globe and it says dumb you'll have
you'll be happy about the other
Democrats relax lang Google's to raise
cash lift $100,000 individual limit
kurbaan non-citizen donations now in
fairness to the Democrats are they doing
it because the Republicans are raising
even more money if you want to know why
the priorities of this country are the
way they all you have to look at
campaign finance reform and you have to
appreciate that the wealthiest one
percent of the population contribute
eighty percent of the campaign donations
that large institutions when we talk
about Bob and I are talking about the
bailout of Chase Manhattan and so forth
it's not an accident the average citizen
does not go to fifty thousand dollar a
plate fundraisings not sleep in the
Lincoln room they contribute you'd sums
of money and they get paid back they get
paid back in tax breaks they get paid
back and absurd trade policies they get
packing it could pay back at a whole lot
of ways pray let me ask you a question I
what do you base your number on your
eighty percent number we both know and
many folks who are watching us do not
that we have limitations with respect to
our personal view page that cannot be
true with respect money what we're
talking about but Hardy money not
individual members of the Congress you
can't use that money I can't use that I
don't have one set in corporate life I'm
not a democrat or republican al so I'm
gonna get the money honey guess you
still buy by the lock let's not be naive
I made if somebody gives right if Newt
Gingrich goes out and has a
fifty-thousand-dollar plate fundraiser
for the Republican Party or the
President of the United States does the
same for the Democratic Party I am sure
that you will agree with me but the
people who are making these huge
contributions are not doing it because
of their concern about civics and the
political so you have political points
of view it's a free country in a little
they won't influence the political
process below that about a lot of
elderly people welcome to let people can
pay for it well I'll let people think
that everybody here is born paid for no
that's not true didn't say that getting
you getting a little defensive about
used to eighty percent I said that the
richest one quarter of one percent of
the population contributes eighty
percent of the campaign fund so that
comes from citizens for responsive
politics I think that's a fact it is if
you want to argue I understand what the
campaign blows are you may not receive
more than two thousand dollars to your
campaign nor can I nor can any other
member of Congress that's true no
corporate money not one cent that's
right on the other hand well not not
true you can get a corporate pack
contribution up to five thousand dollars
of course that's from individuals that's
not cortex Ronnie my own but it's that
president of the chase manhattan bank
gives you five thousand dollars plus
five thousand dollars we can make the
distinct give me five thousand dollars
you know that you just said the limits
individually are one thousand dollars
per site from a pack you can give you
5,000 bucks I mean let's not be naive
but if you're suggesting that big money
does not have an enormous influence over
the political process take money left
and right and it is a free country big
money corporations contribute far more
than unions but here's the point let's
lay on the slavery is do not impact this
legal union certainly do but they're
ugly bank ratting party absolutely
absolutely no course they contribute 35
million dollars that's an enormous sum
of money but you know what that's one
seventh of what corporations put in so I
think are Republicans and Democrats
mostly when the Democrats controlled
this Congress this house the
majority of business money coming to
this hill what the Democrats that's a
good point you know where that leaves me
I'm an independent I'm not a Democrat
and I'm not a Republican and that's one
of the reasons why because I think this
place and please understand I am i agree
with you i dislike when somebody
everybody in Washington is the sale your
corrupt dumb Krum that's nonsense as you
know many people you have different
points of view they work very hard today
are not corrupting sorry but what is
corrupt is a system is a system which
says to the ordinary working person you
got one vote but it says to the ordinary
millionaire and billionaire you got one
vote plus the fact you can contribute
hundreds of thousands of dollars to the
Democratic Party or the Republican Party
you're going to get into the White House
you're going to get in to speak to mr.
Gingrich and you're going to get your
point if you heard I think we're getting
some common ground here if you want to
get to a caller ID like to make a good
point I umbria I'd be interested to hear
your view on this after my column with
respect to where we set with the limits
I understand you think the whole systems
basically corrupt but I think with
respect to the way individual members
are elected in the system in place and
the limits and the limitations have been
in place for a long time post-watergate
and all that it generally works I think
you're talking about the presidential
system was just absolutely far apart and
the party system with respect to
softball I don't think it's honestly I
don't think it generally works let's
look at the result the result is that it
we're having an election you're coming
up in 98 I'm coming up in 90 right
two-thirds of the American people aren't
going to vote they're so disgusted with
the system that they don't even they
don't even want to participate I don't
know the tutorial folks in my district
do that they're not going to vote in the
next of the Brady eight election let me
get a call in this I'm going to do two
again stickney Illinois is next on the
Republican lines good morning hello
you're on the air sir okay yeah we're
right outside of Chicago so I'm
listening to this and being a Republican
and the Democratic cities kind of
interesting I know the feeling uh first
off I'd like to thank c-span I just love
everything you guys have been showing it
really helps to get involved in the
political process even though I'm not a
billionaire with money to throw all over
the place I still like to see politics
and who gets it and wider getting it and
shows like yours help Bernie made a
remark about the uneven distribution
Shin of wealth in this country net that
bothers me because I don't see anything
that says where we have to distribute
wealth a certain way and then he said
like twenty two percent of our kids are
in the worst poverty level and I can't
think of another country that I would
want to be in the poverty level than
here and these remarks are just
bothering me because it seems like you
pick on the people with money just
because they got money hey it's class
warfare and it's very effective American
politics yeah and and I mean it it's
like you know I do vote and and like we
got Carol Moseley Braun end and I don't
know how much money was given to her but
I didn't vote for her because I thought
her ethics weren't that well and and I
don't know if it's voter app excuse me
have to see and just the you know
politics in general then they're just
discussed it but you know I don't see
how money can turn around and make
somebody that's not liked get in okay
but let me just if I made to the
gentleman I unfortunately and I think
Bob will agree with me I mean the
statistics are fairly clear if I'm gonna
run against you and I have ten times
more money than you because I've
accessed a whole lot of money I'm gonna
beat you most of the time whether or not
look at it really that's the fact money
talks that's why these guys are out
hustling money all the time by mr.
Gingrich a mystical it and whole huge
fundraisers the ring at all kinds of
money unfortunately that's the way it is
and that's why we need campaign finance
reform well if I can just make a let me
compliment my friend over here who are
socialists Democratic Socialist
Democratic Socialist Bernie believes in
his heart and we argue and debate in the
House Banking Committee all the time
what he says and God bless him he
believes it and I is his great integrity
we disagree on everything but his great
integrity and I respect him but class
warfare and I think the color makes a
very good point is a very effective tool
in American politics Bill Clinton has
perfected it if you can get that person
making twenty four thousand five hundred
dollars a year to be jealous or resent
that person making thirty six thousand
dollars a year you can get that person's
vote and that's a very effective tool in
American politics today the other point
I think the car made I think it's fair
think Bernie may be compelled to agree
with
30 in this country you're not comparing
it to poverty and some other countries
particularly third world countries I
hope not no of course not but we all
compared good let's let's deal with the
two issues when we talk about
distribution of the wealth wealth in
America let's be clear that the United
States has the most unfair distribution
of wealth in the autumn are lots of
statistical fact in the industrialized
used to be great britain the great
royalty but it's no longer the case and
as a nation what we have to determine is
whether or not it is appropriate
appropriate but there is good public
policy right here in the capital to
continue a process by with y which we
see a proliferation of millionaires and
billionaires yet an increase in poverty
by which the wealthiest one percent on
forty two percent of the wealth now am i
talking about jealousy am i jealous that
some guy is driving out with a big
limousine and has billions alls that's
not the issue the issue is in fact there
is something to a zero-sum game and when
we give tax breaks to billionaires and
cut back on programs for the elderly and
the children frankly i think that that
is unfair now how this thing compounds
itself is when the rich get richer and
when they end up owning you have General
Electric owning NBC and Westinghouse
owning CBS and controlling but goes on
media controlling the newspapers and so
forth and so on giving huge sums of
money to the political pies when you
have a lot of money you're able to
develop public policy which helps
yourself the average guy is working 40
50 60 hours a week making thirty
thousand dollars a year they don't
contribute 50 thousand dollars to the
Gingrich or audit Bill Clinton so that's
why in my view the rich get rich I think
we have to address that issue now when
you talk about what goes on in the rest
of the world of course you know we can't
compare what goes on the United States
to Uganda but we should be known we
should note that in many Scandinavian
countries for example you have a
national health care system which
guarantees health care to all people you
have educational opportunity higher
educational opportunity open to all
people you have people who get six seven
six weeks paid vacation that the
standard of living in many of those
countries is now higher and for the
average American marginal tax rates
being 5067 tax rates are higher but also
very often in a progressive way the
question is not taxes in general the
question is who pays taxes my bottom
line is it is not up to Bob Ehrlich or
any member of that
house to make the moral judgment that
somebody is too rich or too poor I want
to I want everybody to have an
opportunity at the american pie and i
have to tell you this despite all the
influence that you've talked about in
all the great corporate money coming to
this hill into the presidential races we
now have a larger welfare state than we
ever have in the state of maryland we
have an effective marginal tax rate of
fifty percent you work half of the year
today as a citizen of the state of
maryland to pay local state and federal
taxes but finds a very large government
government obviously should do some
things but it is gigantic they sound
like some of those campaign ads they're
in against me not quite accurate next is
a call as we talked to Bob Ehrlich and
Bernie Sanders both members of house
representatives are call us from north
webster Indiana on the Democratic line
good morning morning I was very
interested in this arrogant young man
sitting side of you that tells us old
senior citizens we're making too much
money we get eight hundred dollars a
month and we pay four hundred dollars in
prescriptions can you beat that would
you like to live on that well thank you
for calling me young but I don't know
where you got the bob answer Corey a
good question I don't think I said that
you were making too much money you said
that you want to that the possibility
may exist as I understand what that the
inflation rate is too high for I said
that some economies have stated that and
I said that the executive branch but the
bureau of labor statistics should make
that judgment and if it is too high you
would support lower of course well then
you answer the woman's question she says
she's paying four hundred dollars a
month for prescription drugs and she
gets 800 also Social Security tell her
why you got a low her Social Security
check ma'am do you understand what we're
talking about is that line well I think
I understand swishes bright does is
class warfare and sublime a little
television my lord attorney you want to
make it 1800m listen what this movement
is saying is what goes on in my state
people can't afford their prescription
drugs and they're getting eight hundred
dollars a month in Social Security that
is obscene what is the appropriate level
of government spending in your view in
my teens
in my view the appropriate process is to
make certain that every man woman and
child in this very wealthy country lives
in dignity now you say a great well gee
is that a big indignity she has let's
get him to her situated on't know the
facts of her situation she just all of
us I understand that she just told us if
we accept that his truth and I don't
know why she's going to call you up and
tell you not sure it's not unusual old
people as you know your district in my
dishonor spent 400 bucks a month on
social on medicine right old folks and
you're gonna have in mind this album get
here well not unusual people get ten
twelve thousand dollars you and social
scarce right so she is talking for is
for millions of elderly people I am
saying this gets back to the point we
discussed earlier that there is
something a little bit obscene when we
lower taxes with billionaires and we
tell that senior citizen that we've got
to cut back on a social security or we
can't afford to help with your not
pretending that the majority of the
elder in this country or poor or in
poverty because that's not the case you
know that I think those are striking I
didn't say them but what I am saying and
I'm sorry I don't have the statistics in
front of me but there are many many
elderly people in this country who are
having a hard time getting by and it is
mythology to say oh the old folks are
doing really great some of them are some
of them are not many of the innocent
it's very legitimate for the government
at all levels to help those who cannot
help them solve then you gotta clearly
the elderly who are living in a Harvard
and what are we going to do about this
woman who is living on eight hundred
dollars a month Social Security pay four
hundred dollars per session let's let's
look at her situation very mrs. look at
a situation because sometimes the
stories that I here aren't exact well
Ruth and let's assume that this woman
who suddenly called up see spread is
completely fact she's really good 20
year old millionaire just playing a
millionaire again it's always a
millionaire Allah first let's assume
that you but you will agree with me
there are millions of folks of course so
that's the point and I think that we
help then he is a moral responsibility
in a civilized society that we don't see
people like that suffer at the same time
as you give tax breaks to billionaires
are we getting a glimpse of debates on
the Banking Committee well I'll tell you
one thing we should sell tickets to the
house back in community because we get
very interesting in there winston-salem
North Carolina good morning here on our
independent
today yes I'd like to ask a question
please in regards the articles which
were in on the front page this morning
in the winston-salem journal and it has
to do with tobacco and that's a big
issue now fourth winston-salem is a big
tobacco company think tobacco city
actually with RJ orbit and we had this
we have those stories on our front pages
here as well so let me show them on the
camera for people who haven't yet picked
up their paper yet and it's you're
talking about the the memos that they've
discovered internal RJR memos which
detail that they actually did target
children in their cannons yes ma'am that
is correct that's the same art that's
what I would like that both congressman
about and my question is this I have a
couple of two or three questions
actually but they're all related number
one did either one of the congressman
receive money in their reelection
campaigns from tobacco sources and
secondly i think it would be amiss well
maybe a misinterpretation on some
individuals or people groups park to
think that everyone which would live in
the tobacco city so to speak is
supportive of that tobacco culture they
are not they absolutely are not as a
matter of fact i think there's a vast
well I don't know that but I think there
would be a silent majority which would
say no we don't support it but we just
don't speak against it around here
secondly at the top of our newspaper
today there is a at the main henchman it
tells about RJ our marketing executive
sports marketing executive dies in
boating accident with six or seven other
people then right beside it kind of a
sidebar item almost they have a story
about how this public relations
individual was so kind to help someone
child who had cancer or whatever and to
come beach sports stars and what have
you in NASCAR racing no I thought it was
all just putting all those three
articles together just how in some ways
how hypocritical India say well we want
to do this and make it public relations
value out of this yet we target the
young children to try to hook them own
tobacco okay thank you for your call
will get some comments from our guests a
lot of questions and what's call there
this is very damaging obviously of
simply because it's contrary to the the
view that the tobacco companies have put
out or at least RJR okay this is this
pretend this concerns RJR believe with
respect to their marketing to underage
smokers and so it's certainly very
damaging I am NOT going to question the
motives of the person you refer to with
respect to the article I don't know that
person I think you can be a good person
and work for our junior I do think that
I do think this is obviously a very
damaging now I think there are two
issues with respect to tobacco one is
with respect to underage smoking and I
think we're as a general agreement
Bernie on the hill or in our society
generally that this kind of marketing
should not occur people under age should
not smoke but I think a lot of what
we've done is kind of working around the
edges with respect to the the bottom
line issue here is which I have not
heard anybody have the guts to talk
about this point to this point in time
which is do we at a bottom line one to
outlaw smoking in this country because a
lot of the interest groups out there and
a lot of the debate and a lot of the
political movement obviously a moot is
moving toward that bottom line I think
we should have the guts to debate that
as a bottom line matter with respect to
policy on the sill at some point in time
with respect to your question about
contributions i believe i received a
check or two in my campaigns from our
junior and negligible amount so i want
the for you let me I just want it
because i want to put RJR side of the
story on the table just
arniston they and this is the front page
story in The Washington Post and they
said yesterday RJR repeated its denial
that it had targeted young people and
said it remains committed to reduction
of youth smoking documents were taken
out of context the company said quote
our documents reflect the social
attitudes of the times in which they
were created and while attitudes towards
smoking have changed over the past
several decades Reynolds position and
policy have remained constant that
smoking is a choice for adults and
marketing programs are directed to those
at above the legal age to smoke the
company said well to answer the call
this question though I don't take any
money from the tobacco interest I don't
take any money from any corporate
interest I don't think I can represent
working people and represent good
cooperation so I don't take any money
from corporate interest second of all I
must confess that I'm not terribly
shocked about what's in the story I
think these guys have been lying for 30
years so nothing surprises me I think
you're dealing with executives who are
peddling death and doing some really
horrible things one of the very scary
things I was looking to the commissioner
of health in the state of Vermont I
don't know how it is in Ireland well but
a lot of young kids now girls especially
are taking up smoking they think it's
cool and it's a very sad situation so I
think you have people have been peddling
death I've been lying and I think we
should go after them and go after them
very very hard right get to my second
issue that I think most people would
agree that targeting to underage youth
is is indefensible but with respect to
the bottom line in view of your previous
comment what is your view concerning
should we outlaw at the state love with
the federal level smoking I think there
is add that debate yet I think you're
right i think that is a good debate I
don't off the top of my head and not
having studied intensively I don't think
you tell millions of people are smoking
today that they're committing an
unlawful lap but on the other hand i
agree i think on the other hand the
evidence seems to be i don't claim to be
a scientist on this issue the evidence
seems to be growing the nicotine is a
drug a habit-forming drug and i think
you will agree with me that we don't
like habit-forming drugs whether it's
heroin cocaine or nicotine so I think
you're going to see the federal
government I know you may not feel
comfortable the federal government
moving in this direction but the FDA
regulating the use of nicotine
regulating used to make a team but
keeping the product legal we will see
what happens in use is adult behavior is
a free country it's very
interesting line here but I think you'll
agree that debate at least a lot of the
interest groups have come in on the
debate are moving toward the bottom line
ultimately of a policy goes outlawing
the availability of cigarettes well I
think it's an issue bottom line for me
at least is that we should be looking at
nicotine as a habit-forming drug and
seeing what we can do about it and in
terms of the tobacco industry they've
been lying for 30 years so there's
nothing that should surprise anybody
raleigh north carolina is next on the
Republican lines good morning to you
good morning a North Carolinian who
doesn't want to speak about tobacco I'm
surprising today if anybody wants to
they can see the editorial it's a letter
to the editor in the news and observer
and you can get it on Nando and it talks
since they raise questions about the
veterans and cutbacks it tells about a
how they received a piece of information
it's from a doctor and I won't murder
the poor man's name and it was a piece
of paper in an envelope that measured 10
x 14.5 inches and the piece of paper was
3 inches by eight and a half inches and
all it the only information they had in
that large envelope was a change of
address for the veterans department and
he breaks it down into how much waste
there was in what could have gone out on
a 20 cent postcard and went out and cost
at the 8.5 cents to put it in this large
envelope and the postage and I think
it's that type of thing that is really
running up costs and he equates it to
veterans not getting life-saving
medications but this is the kind of
waste and I'd like to make one other
quick comment I think when all is said
and done with this particular president
we are going to find that he did less
governing I am so tired of seeing him
get on a plane to go out and raise money
and basically I'm surprised the congress
hasn't said something how much of our
tax dollars is going for that yes he
stops and visit the school to offset
some of the cost but in recent years I
have never
remember to president being out of the
White House as much as this manda is and
i have a feeling the president clinton
will be shown to have done less
governing and you have to give his
cabinet credit because they certainly
must be doing a job somewhere along the
way because i don't see him doing a lot
he's off he is in love with it Air Force
One and I i'm frankly sick and tired of
seeing them on there every weekend thank
you for your talks well I think the
caller makes a good point that no
question she's absolutely right the
president that he's admitted I mean
there's no great secret so public
information he's running around the
country raising huge sums of money
Republicans in fact are raising more
money and I think what we have to ask
ourselves is a Democratic Society the
propriety of the president of the united
states holding fundraisers at fifty
thousand dollars a plate newt gingrich
doing the same members of Congress
having to spend a whole lots of time
raising money is that really the kind of
democratic society that we want to live
in and I think the answer is we need
campaign finance reform so the President
of the United States Newt Gingrich
members of Congress do not waste their
lives raising money rather than trying
to develop public policy in the best
interest of their constituents well I
have a lot of things to say and I have a
minute Bill Clinton loves the campaign
that's always ever done that's what he
knows best to do he's always been
interested more in campaigning than he
has in running the government so that's
not surprising I do Bernie you may know
the law better and I do in this area the
Democratic National Committee does pay
for a part of these trips that's right
and I'm not sure exactly where the
argument is less right the audio levels
in committee pays for Republican
presidents and all that so it's not all
taxpayer-funded I have to say that I
have to add that in fairness to him but
be aware of politicians who call for
campaign finance reform and i'm going to
ask Bernie to define his terms but
everybody supports campaign finance
reform right I support campaign finance
reform and I don't think the system is
fundamentally corrupt at the
Congressional level I think the system
is broken down completely at the
presidential level which is a different
system also with respect to the comment
concerning veterans veterans spending to
a man and woman on the
he'll veterans are a number one priority
I think you raised a good point there is
waste in the system to the extent there
is waste those dollars are not going to
where it should go for those dollars are
not going to where they should go which
is veteran's health care so I think that
that point is very well taken it's one
thing to talk about spending it's
another thing to talk about efficient
spending particularly in the VA system I
think we agree on that I mean no but
course I mean no one is going to die for
a moment that there's not a whole lot of
waste which we've got to get a handle on
but where Bob and I I think disagree is
is is the nature of the campaign finance
system right now i think it is corrupt
and by that I don't mean individual but
what I mean is the system as a whole you
may be reading for example in the papers
and the viewers should notice that in
California now more recent special
elections what happens is if you're
running for office you have to raise a
certain amount of money you got to go
through the hoops but if Susan besides
being a good citizen that she doesn't
like you or she likes me she is able to
put independent expenditures into the
television in the way I had that against
me when I ran some group of corporate
executives didn't like me and they
completely separate from my Republican
opponent porting huge sums of money on
30 second negative ads they can do that
all over the place now get into me okay
so you tell me you're the laughter of
course as I say though you know
corporate america spends a lot more than
jeans but be that as it may it's absurd
it is absurd if I'm gonna run against
you right let's say you and I are
running we have different points of view
and you and I agree that you know we
believe we're honest we believe in what
we stand for and we want them we want to
express our point of view to the voters
right that's what an election is about I
think roughly speaking we should be
starting from a level playing field I
don't think you have the right or I have
the right to have ten times more money
coming into the election than you do I
agree with that by the way but how we
get there is where we disagree are you
talking about public financing i'm
talking about a combination let me give
me a second here this you know i can
summarize it in for a sec it's not a
sound byte program yeah i'm talking
about a consoling either one a
combination of things number one I'm
talking about eliminating soft money so
that you get no help from the Republican
Party well nobody gets help from the
Democratic
so the people cannot contribute hundreds
of thousands dollars to either party
right that's number one and number two
what I'm talking about is a combination
effect this number one if you really
have support in your community go out
and get twenty five dollar contributions
fifty dollar contributions and the
federal government should match those
contributions contribution for
contribution you get a thousand-dollar
contribution federal government doesn't
put any more than two hundred dollars in
so it's a combination of getting you to
depend on small donations a large number
of small donations plus government
matching those grants how are you going
to make this inherently fair because as
an incumbent forget the money we have
name recognition you don't buy that you
or you have to buy that as a challenger
so how much are you going to penalize me
as an incumbent in order to start out
from the gates even that's a very fair
question and I'm not for a moment
suggesting this whole process is simple
or I have every I dotted but I should
tell you that in my own state of Vermont
I'm very proud of we passed campaign the
state legislature passed campaign
finance law consistent with what I'm
saying and in fact it gives the
challenge if my memory is correct more
money allows that challenge that have
more money than the ax comment because
it presumes that the incumbent has
better name working and I would suspend
contribution limits with respect to
challenger so I'm i think our bottom
line is the same is how we get there is
where we differ so question on campaign
finance reform from a viewer by email
who asked would representative Sanders
overly favor reform in which legal
contributions to a candidate can be made
only by people who can vote for that
candidate uh if if we limited the total
amount of money that I can't that an
individual can contribute now I come
from a small state for a lot of members
of Congress that comes from very poor
districts where many of their supporters
don't have a whole lot of money to
contribute on the other hand if you
represent wealthy people and have a
fundraiser for a thousand dollars a
piece you can raise a whole lot of money
so if you limited the amount that
somebody they could contribute to a
hundred dollars for two hundred dollars
that's a good idea if you don't that's a
bad idea I I interpret the question to
me those who live in your district is
that correct it goes on to say why is it
legitimate for a person running office
and Pennsylvania to accept money from
persons because we're the United States
Congress and we vote on federal taxpayer
dollars in taxpayer dollars from the
United States taxpayer go around the
world so I
it is they don't like this and I think
it's unconstitutional boot daytona beach
florida good morning on the Democratic
line good morning I'd like to preface my
comments by saying that only a few years
ago I was a Republican however I had to
change my party affiliation and the
gentleman there from Maryland is a
perfect example of that of the abject
hypocrisy of the Republican Party and
the people that espouse their points of
view is primary reason I had to switch
I've always been admirer of mr.
representative Sanders and even more so
since i've seen in carrollton TV this
morning number one he the gentleman from
Maryland could not answer with a
straight face the ladies questions they
called in about receiving eight hundred
dollars a month and Social Security and
having to pay four hundred dollars for
her prescription medicine he
conveniently dodged that I dare say that
that he is a he's covered by a quote
national type health insurance however I
would be fairly certain that he voted
against that he's probably voted against
the increase in the minimum wage which
was recently passed I believe two years
ago and is also coming up for a vote by
proposal i believe by the President and
Senator Kennedy Mr Sanders on the other
hand speaks to the needs of the common
what I call the working middle class
people and I admire him for that all
right sir thanks since you've
complimentary Sanderson criticizes mr.
Ehrlich that's mr. Orlok respond sir you
should not be Republican if you entire
heard Mr Sanders is a friend of mine but
I have no idea why you were ever a
Republican and view of what you've said
secondly with respect to minimum wage
and Bernie knows us very well when you
raise the minimum wage you help some
poor people and you put the most
marginal in the workforce those who do
not have the skills to compete at the
higher wage level out of business out of
employment I don't think that's a very
compassionate thing for government to do
setting an artificial wage rate it does
not help it hurts the most marginal
helpless uneducated
the workforce almost all the economist's
out there agree with respect to that
point with respect to lady who called in
I said this the government does have a
place to play with respect to those who
are in poverty and elderly and cannot
cannot help themselves I obviously could
not comment with respect to her
situation I wouldn't dare to neither
would with Bernie but certainly
government has a role to play the issue
here is how large do you want government
to get how large is the nanny state the
welfare state going to get we can be
compassion play the compassionate game
with respect to politics all day long
but at some point the people who work in
this country who deserve a standard of
living commence with with their hard
work deserve not to have the government
take more than half of the money that
they have earned through their own toils
that's where I'm coming from I'm a
conservative I'm a supply signer I'm
going to apologetic about it we disagree
you should support Mr Sanders and his
party I what I don't have a party but I
thank the gentleman very much for his
foot let me talk about the minimum wage
Bob that's the line that we heard two
years ago when we fought to raise the
minimum wage from about four and a
quarter an hour and we had dick armey
and I gather what you're saying yourself
saying gee whiz we can't raise the
minimum wage above four and a quarter an
hour which was at that point a minimum
wage with a purchasing power I believe
forty percent less than it was some 20
or 30 years ago now we can't do that
because it's a resulting job loss well
we've raised them we fought and as a
result of seventy or eighty percent of
the american people saying to mr.
gingrich and folks like you raise the
minimum wage finally we got some
republicans to vote and we raise the
minimum wage to all the 515 an hour and
you know what Bob all of those
predictions about job loss at how poor
people are going to suffer turned out to
be what many of us predicted to the
total nonsense of fact there has been a
proliferation of new jobs being created
in the economy it wasn't true then it's
not sure now now the bottom line is I
get frankly very tired of hearing from
all kinds of economist and from all
kinds of media people you know in the
corporate media telling us how great the
economy is doing I don't think the
economy is doing so great and I think
the reason the economy is not doing so
great
is that low-income workers today in
America are have a purchasing power
significantly less than it was 15 or 20
years ago in my state and throughout
this country and I suspect in Maryland
as well you have women who are thoughts
to work you know we hear a lot of these
folks talking about family values we
want mom to stay home with the kids you
know what mom can't stay home with the
kids because mom has to go out with dad
to earn a living to pay for food and for
college education for the kids and one
of the reasons for that is that wages
are too low yes I know the dick armey
thinks we should eliminate the minimum
wage and if a willing worker wants to
work for two bucks an hour and a willing
employer wants to pay that so be it I
kind of think that slavery so I am will
I have legislation and we complete that
will raise the minimum wage the six
dollars and fifty cents an hour because
i want to see everybody who works in
this country not live in poverty why not
750 good boy well why not eight fit
let's look you go for 750 my why not ten
fellow let's not go too high that's
compassion for weight me too high wait
that's a moral judgment Bernie [ __ ]
you're gonna go I not sit oh you're mine
oh my god it's gonna send artificial way
Joanne stop bugging everybody out of
poverty well once you go will you
support oh no will you support me with
650 absolutely not okay why not you go
dollars in your view because there are
at certain levels without being absurd
at certain levels will have a negative
impact on the economy what love what
well certainly not at 515 I think we can
go to Six fit those folks that we put
out of work last year excuse me the most
morally or do not call in your office my
office they are not registry voters I
thought that unemployment that was
reference they have a bob unemployment
today the problem with our economy is
not high unemployment as you may have
seen on the front pages of all the
papers unemployment in fact is quite low
it's a problem at no i don't what I do
disagree with is that the wage situation
is country is horrendous people are
working but they're not making enough
money and letting everybody up let's
bring everybody that's a good let's do
that so let's talk my raison get
opportunity let's not put people into
work who are worth five not an angel
employer they're not what you want to do
that it's not compassionate off it's
Bob we heard that our gratuity we heard
the argument two years ago [ __ ] we heard
that I commit it was wrong gentlemen you
told this was a small business sir yeah
let me jump in cuz we only have about a
minute and a half left with one callers
been waiting a long time fort lauderdale
florida you're gonna be our last thanks
thank you very much good morning first I
want to compliment both gentlemen on the
very active debate this morning in a
very professional manner it's greatly
appreciated for a change I've been an
independent all my life and I have a
couple quick questions first for
congressman Ehrlich why is it okay to
make a moral judgment about personal
family value issues such as prayer in
school or aunt abortion or abortion
rights yet we can't make moral judgments
about the amount of money people might
make and what they can do with it
regarding the caller who is making eight
hundred dollars on social security and
paying 400 for prescription we all kept
looking at it from the point of view is
how much more do we need to give her out
of a program yet what about looking at
the four hundred dollars it's costing
for those prescriptions instead it's
been argued and very successfully over
the past few years that pharmaceuticals
charge way too much for prescription
medicine I own stock and work I know
they're making a huge amount of money
and you're benefiting a little bit there
finally on the issue of President
Clinton that the crawler made about
going out and spending more time out in
the country rather than in the oval
office making decisions the wonderful
thing about modern technology is you can
govern from almost anywhere and I think
most congressional leaders know that and
most congressmen know that because they
go home to their constituents quite
frequent was it frequently the one thing
I can say is that my age about 40 years
old I've finally my life had the
opportunity to meet both a vice
president and a president which I don't
think you get to do very often and
that's without donating one penny as
opposed to investigating each other and
running up high legal costs and I am a
law school making lawyers a lot richer
than they probably could or should be
okay thanks to be able to go its top of
the hour gentlemen so short response I
think she made a great point I find that
very hard that these guys say a woman
wants to have an abortion she can't have
it that's terrible we're concerned about
people who may be gay but gee it's
inappropriate for the government to say
that we should ask the rich to pay their
fair share of taxes that we helped the
working people for terms of prescription
drugs she's also quite right we pay
more for prescription drugs in this
country that almost any other country on
earth it is an outrage and I legislation
and to try to deal with starla classroom
I guess a little bit more about my
politics we probably would agree on your
first statement and if you see my voting
record I suspect you would see that it
reflects your review I just turned 42 so
I'll close on that note is this a good
thing try not sure that's true gentlemen
thanks so much for being here first hour
this morning appreciate your time hope
you'll both come back congressman Bernie
Sanders of Vermont and congressman Bob
Ehrlich of Maryland we have two hours
ahead we'll be back in just a couple of
minutes we'll be talking next about the
Middle East peace process